[Sebastian:] Thank you Kathleen. I really appreciate it.
This code has a little bit more stuff than you just talked about.
It actually assimilates noise, but the noise filters are all set to 0,
and those noise filters are really important for particle filters
so you can play with those if you like.
In fact, there's a function over here called set noise.
It allows you to set them,
and then later on we have a function that makes kind of no sense right now,
but really important as we implement particle filters called measurement probability,
and this accepts a measurement and tells you how plausible this measurement is.
It's kind of the key thing for the survival of the fittest rule in particle filters.
So, if you look through the codes don't be confused by this function; we will actually use it later.